European experts say they've used a
popular technology to develop a medical
procedure that could be life-changing
for millions of people Naomi ruckham is
here with more Naomi good morning good
morning Dana that's right researchers
used implants with Bluetooth technology
the same that's in your phone to help a
paralyzed person walk again just by
thinking about it
for over a decade the steps you are
seeing were physically impossible for 40
year old George on oscome 12 years ago I
got a accident and had a spinal cord
injury his legs were fully paralyzed and
his arms partially paralyzed but today
he is back on his feet using a walker
thanks to a so-called digital bridge
between his brain and the nerves below
his injury within five to ten minutes I
could control my hips when asgom thinks
about walking electrodes on his brain
relay the message to electrodes on his
spinal cord this signal is wirelessly
transmitted by a computer that oscom
wears in a backpack which then sends the
information to a pulse generator on his
spine our idea was to re-establish this
communication with a digital Bridge an
electronic communication between the
brain and the region of the spinal cord
that is still intact in a 2018 trial an
implant was placed in oscom spine while
he saw Improvement his progress
plateaued after three years that
original spinal implant is currently
paired with two disc shaped implants
inserted into his skull now when Austin
thinks about walking the skull implants
detect electrical activity in his brain
the patient has first to learn how to
work with his brain signals and we also
have to learn how to correlate this
brain signal to the spinal cord
stimulation after around 40
Rehabilitation sessions using the brain
spine interface oscom can now walk short
distances without the device if he uses
assistance allowing him to regain his
independence one step at a time I can
really build functional things from it
to just an example I'm training 10 years
to stand up with a friend
having a beer
and that's something I think people
don't realize
another bit of optimism oscom's doctors
say not only did he regain control of
some of his muscles but they also
noticed the growth of new nerve
connections amazing guys oh unreal
groundbreaking I remember Christopher
Reeve imagining this would help him in
his life after he was paralyzed and here
we are at some 25 years later slowly but
surely get in there yeah wonderful